[Musique]
allez on va démarrer par enora votre
appréciation et votre note pour mathieu
de l'an alors alors déjà d'extraits que
vous avez choisi vous ne le dirais juste
après a juste après d'accord matthieu
delormeau les points faibles il chiant
il la ramène tout le temps et c'est
toujours la lumière sur lui
il coupe aussi un peu la parole aux gens
où on est rarement d'accord on puisse
après l'eucharistie avec ça je peux rien
parfois il se caricature un peu mais les
points forts c'est qu'une émission sans
mathieu delormeau un tp m p 100 matthieu
delormeau cpnt pmp quand même le social
tu es devenu mais plus qu elle
essentielle à l'émission moi quand tu
n'es tout le monde est essentiel est
rare en tout cas pour ma part tu m'as
menti et dans la vie tu es quelqu'un
d'extraordinaire d'un coeur énorme
tu es toujours d'humeur égale toujours
souriant toujours un mot gentil en tout
cas me confirmant si si c'est bien de
matthieu delormeau deux allers retours
il m'a même invité une fois au
restaurant situé à inviter une seule
fois c'est vous qui avait payé à mon
avis peut-être ans crève non vraiment je
leur trouve extraordinaire et cette
année je te trouve meilleur que l'an
passé
parce que là tu fais plus d analyse
médias je trouve c'est pas toujours très
intelligent mais au moins tu es tu
essayes de faire d alice media c'est pas
mal et moi je vous avez bien fait de
dire accepter voilà qui pointe toujours
très intelligent
non mais moi je laime très très fort
c'est mon ami je lui met huit
c'était quoi votre extrait de matthieu
delormeau
c'est alors qu'est ce que c'est mais le
matthieu delormeau un peu tendre un peu
doux doux avec pascal obispo
à un moment j'ai retenu chez un ami
derrière mazout on met lass mathieu
c'est moi tu si il ya des soirs comme ça
où tout
s'écroule autour de nous
les devants soir
quand jamais baisser les bras je sais je
suis pas le remède à tous
il faut source et parfois mathieu
le temps
c
ces deux-là mois
[Applaudissements]
pascal toutefois qu'il avait sauvé ce
jour là merci mon pascal votre note 8
donc bravo c'est bien mais bon alors je
t'avais midi points puis après j'ai
commencé à en retirer un peu importe à
méchanceté mathieu à l'égard de calcul
de ma jamin de moi un pour ta radinerie
parce que lé légendaire important côté
fayot à l'égard de cyril b71 pour tes
tenues
tu as carton en quarante deux ans et tu
t'habilles comme un garçon de 15 ans 1
pour tes analyses souvent foireuse mais
ça je verrai ça que j leur parler comme
sur une lazio pour ta tentative de
corruption hier parce que tu m'as quand
même promis un prime je sais pas comment
tu peux en avoir le pouvoir le plus con
c'est toi qui as cru non pas du tout non
non tu voir la note apporte énormément
car tu es un bien près piètre acteur il
reste 3 il en reste 3 donc effectivement
je te laisse trois points importants
physique et 2 pour la place que tu
prends dans tpm puisque tu prends
beaucoup beaucoup de place donc 3,3 à
quoi tu prend 1,3 dans la gueule il est
tout tout le monde m'a donné son avis
rien jusqu'à dimanche soir
alors on va pas faire que les
actionnaires explique l extrême de leur
modèle et parker allée jean michel maire
c'est votre pote c'est mon pote
exactement mais là c'est pas n'importe
que je vais juste c'est le chroniqueur
alors ça va aller vite parce que je
trouve que c'est
on l'emploie un peu comme l'homme à tout
faire le thé pmp ça tombait à la 6è tout
faire il sait danser il sait imiter
liste des amis avec grâce il est
toujours de bonne humeur
c'est un bon camarade c'est vrai voilà
et tu sais soulever de la fonte putelat
libyen tu es le plus propre d'entre nous
avaient sous vêtements toujours
impeccable la vie et pour approuver
l'émission média c'est important les
plus propres
ça t'a dit pas une émission médias mais
je pense pour un être humain c'est juste
ça c'est super bizarre mais c'est sûr
que je suis bien le voyagiste a une
vraie expérience de la télévision il a
travaillé sur plusieurs choses plusieurs
chaînes plus intelligents qu'on le croit
et tu es très sensible donc pour toutes
ces belles raisons je ne pouvais pas te
mettre d'autres notent que 10
mais ce n'est apparemment pas trop
d'idées planète qui m'a mis non mais il
se destine aux jean-michel d'antenne et
deux derrière vous avez voulu donner
beaucoup je trouve qu'il est essentiel
n'est pas discutée n'avait pas dix ans
capucine dana alors mathieu
donc quand on s'est connu tu étais tout
entouré de canif et de bergers allemands
puisque tu présenter ou fin serait assez
sympa nous rappeler les bons souvenirs
depuis tu es devenu une star dans tp mpt
important pour l'émission la preuve tu
es la star des 4 pierre à défaut d'être
la star d'un prime oui ton point fort
c'est évidemment tu acceptes tout ce que
te demandes si reed là il te demande de
déguisant mylène farmer tu le sais bon
il faut faire des loisirs
c'est ce que j'allais faire virer pour
démontrer tard es tu fais et le pire
c'est que tu fais avec plaisir un élève
modèle
ton point faible c'est bien évidemment
ton melon mathieu à côté de toi même
alain delon et humble au début ça
[Applaudissements]
fontana et invite à bagnolet la malène
d'olonne et houle
alors oui et donc oui je peux continuer
alors au début donc je croyais que tu
traîner avec moi parce que tu étais mon
ami mais en fait non tu restes avec moi
parce que bas-côté tout à côté de moi au
moins tu te sens intelligent et j'ai
décidé de te mettre la meilleure note
que tu mérites
j'aimerais que tu saches avant que tu
regardes cette note et c'est sincère que
je t'aime de tout mon coeur mais je juge
pas notre amitié je te mets un 4 bat
paravent c'est vrai qu'elle t'aime bien
dans quatre c'est qu'elle peut elle
tomber elle elle vous êtes bien et vous
avez vraiment et non pas ce qu'est ce
qu'elle aime c'est votre mobilité
c'est du beau et tout celle là benjamin
castaldi lumière chez qui vous avez
habité de nombreuses et vous avez habité
ensemble mais non ils habitaient
ensemble allées et venues habiter chez
toi moi après ma gueule l'état non mais
c'est vrai parce qu'en fait et c'était
fini je crois que c'est fini avec sa
flamme à sa meuf fois qu'il avait gerard
way j'avais mis toutes mes affaires dans
la voiture on n'avait que gérard énorme
commis alors ça venait de se terminer
avec gérard alémanique où tu ne sais pas
où aller dormir le beau et si tu peux
les garder chez toi comme j'ai un grand
coeur je les ai accueillis à bras
ouverts
bien sûr il est ouvert que les bras
alors ça c'était à l'époque
parce que je pense que tu dis c'est à
l'époque cirque tête avec fernand a été
bonne à marier mais c'est important
parce que moi je prépare mais aussi mon
truc alors avant de parler de de l'homme
de l'homme audiovisuel je voudrais
d'abord qu'on rende vraiment hommage à
l'artiste qui est temps mathieu et
j'aimerais qu'on voit quelques images de
son côté artistique qu'on rende hommage
à l'artiste laissait matthieu l'annoncé
doublé important devant parce que tu as
fini en tant à dire qu'il est artiste et
qui sont des artistes qui donne de lui
qu'il est depuis qu'il est devant des
salles 2012 à personne donc je voulais
commencer par ces images pour recadrer
vraiment qui est de leurs mots en
artiste alors dit
[Musique]
là c'est la championne elisabeth celle à
jour
[Musique]
hier
parce qu'en fait il s'appelait kader
avons pris s'il fait des boîtes de nuit
mais se fait appeler khadr qui veut plus
bas il fait des boîtes de nuit
il peut m'arriver c'est vrai le week-end
de détente et relaxation
mais parfois c'est autre chose parfois
là pendant ce week-end comme on s'en
fout il a donné son planning
ça fout totalement rappelle mathieu veut
qu'on l'a pas le cas des batailles a pas
de problème mais les bras la beaujoire
samedi pour recadrer l'artiste delormeau
ceci étant posé jeu devrait évoquer vos
qualité d'analyste médiatique mais vu
que le moins de compliments qu'on vous
fait vous fait augmenter un peu plus
votre me l'ont déjà des mesures et je ne
ferai aucun complément
voilà on va gagner du temps si je peux
me permettre
lui il a l'air de bien vous aimez au bas
de la coloc
je connais un peu les relations humaines
jeu souk ahras et ça c'est une phase
normale lorsqu'on trouve son identité
mais je suis le miroir de ce qu'il est
en train de devenir et c'est un petit
peu compliqué pour lui pour ça qu'il un
peu de ma gueule alors je sais pas
l'idée de l'année terminé donc on va
prendre aucun risque on va pas risquer
d'augmenter 7 me le dit on va calmer le
troubadour de l'amour les rebelles
villard des week-ends et bien et je vais
prendre une note qui rime avec ta
prochaine chaîne je vais prendre le 1
comme nt1
[Applaudissements]
tu l'as si vous les mettez un voilà ce
que demandera une info à vous donner sur
mathieu dorval vous dirai si vous êtes
pour ou contre ça ça sera le premier
conseil de famille ne touche pas aux
boss qu'on fera des conseils de famille
tous les jours en début d'émission et
vous nous donnerez votre avis ce sera
d'ailleurs sur mathieu de l'envol pour
le prochain conseil de famille qu'on a
gâché un peu la garde alors mathieu tu
étais mon chouchou
mon préféré vous acceptez avant avant de
te rencontrer cette vous étiez votre
préféré oui mais c'était avant de le
rencontrer
ah oui j'ai changé d'avis maintenant
ceux qui vivotent préféré c'est moi
c'est qu'a pu mais à nadal à ne jamais
rencontrer ses idoles
ouais ouais merci je vais manger trop
tournant encore une fois super c'est
vrai je vois que tu vas lui il ya un
très net
agathe alors je tiens à enterrer
définitivement tous les articles et
rumeurs qui ont fait de matthieu
delormeau une victime malheureuse et
harcelés dans cette émission car mathieu
de leurs monnaies non pas la victime et
le bourreau art avec toujours des
petites remarques désagréables sur le
physique ou sur les interventions de ses
petits camarades ceux qui cachent selon
moi mathieu un certain manque de
confiance en soi à travailler toutefois
je lui reconnais un sens du show et de
la répartie extrêmement précieux pour
cette émission en direct que le
chroniqueur qu'on rêve d'avoir autour de
la table où c'est malin intelligent tu
as du vocabulaire ce qui te permet
parfois de faire passer tes expertise
média foireuse pour une analyse
acceptable voilà on va les battre
jusqu'au bout
les miettes du maniema casse agent m'a
dit pourquoi pas bien ça fait 2
émissions
[Applaudissements]
je fais un bisou en garde parce que elle
elle a dit vraiment beaucoup de choses
se voient ça fait la bise ou deux avant
parce que papa troisième énerve tout le
monde je pense qu'on va l'avoir
on voit l'argent dès le 27 février ah
non moi pardon c'est tabou alors oui
mathieu toutefois regarde moi je l'avais
été très laid qui ont marqué l'année
2016 avec toutes les qualités tout était
faux et je pense que tu fera encore
partie de celles qui vont marquer
l'année 2007 2010 est planté et donc
malgré tes défauts que tu assume
pleinement et avec lesquels tu joue
brillamment je te mets là note de aa à a
[Applaudissements]
le même sort que la note la baisse la
tête et celui qui dit je suis là mais
les fous ceux là isabelle morini bosc
oui alors matthieu delormeau point fort
était omniprésente un point faible
devenu présent oloron dans ta gueule
quand il oui la télé réalité quand il
oublie ses inimitiés foireuse on sait
pas pourquoi karine lemarchand la nuit
là ayem voir stéphane plaza et ben tu as
des monts jugement est toujours présente
souvent les jugements de la france
profonde donc ça moi j'y suis très
sensible nombre de fois tu va à
contre-courant le milieu élitiste gauche
au volant saison plaît bien
3 faible steam tu bouffes l'oxygène dès
que t'arrive quelque part mais vraiment
tu aspires aussi l'air ambiant tu vois
ça c'est quand même à vous n'avez pas de
leurs
même à droite ce genre de robe bon de
faire le conseil de boumerdès il est
l'arbre et comme il est en baisse mais
rien ne dit d'ailleurs moi ce que je
suis je vous êtes bouillant sur le
conseil de l'ue courjault bouillant
alors on va tenter une grande
indifférence envers tout ce qui n'est
pas toi malgré tout je tiens beaucoup à
la fois une bonne et quand même un petit
conseil si tu continues à te dire qu'on
a six générations d'écart alors qu'on en
a qu'une et encore et que toi tu te
teinté de gris c'est tout comme lyon je
t'en plafonne je te grippe je te mords
jeta greenspan
[Applaudissements]
elle tu vois c'est pas et victoire d'un
des poussins
reversât j'aime beaucoup et dont je
t'aime et 7 7 me un an avant
merci mais louis la dot de va les régler
on finira par gilles verdez ya stéphane
paya jean luc lemoine aussi dominateurs
après oprah et valérie bénaïm et gilles
verdez regarder et moncany aussi ben je
voulais dire que mathieu est quelqu'un
qui est indispensable à la démission
l'année dernière et nous a joué sa
grande histoire d'amour à que si reed
cette année il a pris un peu trop la
confiance malheureusement il est
persuadé que seule son avis compte que
c'est plus intéressant de tous et le
problème c'est qu'au début il rigole
avec ça mais maintenant il le croit
hier à mathieu tu habites 4 comme tu vas
être le chroniqueur numéro un et ben moi
aujourd'hui je te mets un bonne soirée
[Applaudissements]
voilà jean luc et a guère de bien c'est
que l'acteur de cadres et hauts lieux
qui t'ont spectacle voiles et les
mairies alors mathieu mathieu mathieu
mathieu mathieu mathieu alors va lever
le nez creux touché un bon élément tuer
c'est vrai parfois drôles parfois
pertinent tu joue le jeu des happenings
tu mouiller la chemise et tu aime
sincèrement cyril même si maintenant il
faudrait quand même songé à lui [ __ ]
la paix quand même au moment je
l'attrapé défier dessus non non non il
faut vraiment le lâcher ce que tu
m'appartiens mai
mathieu ce trimestre tu t'es reposer sur
ses lauriers mon garçon parce que
mathieu tu as créé la surprise l'année
dernière et fort de ces acquis parce que
nous avons tous été surpris on pensait
que tu étais un abruti fini
et tout d'un coup on s'est dit ah bah
tiens il ya quelques il ya quelqu'un il
ya quelque chose ce garçon finalement à
de la tessiture et donc est battu et que
tu as cru que tu pouvais être en roue
libre que tu pouvais ne plus rien [ __ ]
donc monsieur ne vient pas au brief
monsieur arrive avec peut-être une ou
deux heures de retard sur les autres
monsieur voit une émission sur 2 voire
sur trois est monsieur a évidemment un
melon énorme et très peu d'empathie
pastèque
cela dit comme effectivement comme l'a
dit mon l'on dit mes camarades tu quand
même un élément important de l'émission
c'est pour ça et donc je te donne un
avertissement parce qu'effectivement tac
démarré plus tôt platement non mais
ensuite il ya eu jusqu'à un creux ce
malgré des arrivées des mouches de
lipides balaiera sera alors que tu t'es
repris quand même c'est trois quatre
derniers jours
je te mettrai gentiment parce que je
suis une fille extrêmement sympathique
la moyenne 5
camille combal alors et moi alors je
suis un peu loin de tout ça mais alors
je vais mettre la note à matthew je vais
dire mathieu tu aurais eu un 10 l'an
passé mais j'ai l'impression qu'on a
deux matches on a le mathieu de cette
année et le mathieu de l'an passé mais
comme tu est essentielle à l'émission à
cyril au bon déroulement non il n'est
pas vraiment bon en plateau et donc moi
je te mets un très beau 6 ainsi que
[Applaudissements]
matthew moulay rachid
mais tu es sorti de la carotte
j'ai plein de fruits et légumes
je vous dis ouais tiens alors mathieu
sylla qui à m sila qui nous envoie la
note ont maintenant à m qu'on embrasse
qui nous regardent je mets un indice à
mathieu parce qu'il m'a dit qu'il
m'invite le resto non mais je vais aller
après mais pardon faute de frappe
je mets 1 1 0 1 voilà
[Applaudissements]
allez on a des notes pour mathieu nord
mosquée c'est son conseil de cassation
rappelle je leur ai ma note dans un
instant et on attend la note de gilles
verdez avec impatience bien entendu il y
a quelqu'un vous avez beaucoup critiqué
c'est stéphane plaza qui voulez vous
mettre une note
regardez mathieu battu mathieu c'est
vrai que ça doit être compliqué de
passer d'animateur à chroniqueurs on te
sent plein de frustration
le gang qui fait beaucoup de bruit pour
rien c'est toi tu devrait investir moins
dans le sport est plus dans les matières
fondamentales
sinon tu vas doublés voire triplés et le
directeur hanouna et ben il va finir par
tes sq lui pour conserver cette très
bonne réputation des merlus nous quitte
a fait une petite vidéo etc tu as
d'autres gars beaucoup c'est de gaulle à
12 jaunes alors le point fort de mathieu
c'est qu'il est beau le point faible de
mathieu c'est qu'il est con c'est un
beau conte alors c'est pour cela que je
te donne la note de 10
ça moi rigoler on a la note des civières
des âmes ont bien sûr d'avoir la note
hier françois virot qui donne à ce qu'il
a d'autres soucis moi c'est pas les
n'est pas prêt de le dédier à mon avis
là ça vient du tout françois fillon l'a
il donne pas des notes l' île aux deux à
la limite donner des emplois fictifs
mais pas des mathieu bref plein de
points forts franchement et je vais
commencer par un mea culpa je pensais
que mallié pas trouvé votre place dans
cette émission je vous l'avais dit vous
êtes devenu un élément incontournable
quand vous n'êtes pas là je vous cherche
parce que je ne sais plus qui fera
qu'assez votre présence mais vraiment
importante
et oui vous avez votre place autour de
la table et c'est avec beaucoup de
sincérité et d'émotion que je vous
accorde indices
[Applaudissements]
j'ai fait ça dans un premier temps puis
je me suis dit que vous aviez aussi des
points faibles je me suis dit que ses
points faibles
elles permettent là on a le droit ce
soir ag2r des deux comédiens ses ruelles
ses points faibles
j'ai sélectionné juste les meilleurs
parce que j'avais pas le temps de tous
les prendre
défaut alors bon je vais pas tout
énumérer mais vous êtes mythomane
réinventer tout de nous raconter quelque
chose c'est faux vous devez faire un
démenti le lendemain vous êtes égoïstes
vous êtes méchant mais pourquoi tant de
haine et un problème dans la petite
enfance est ce que c'est incroyable
cette feignant c'est vrai vous arrivez
tout le temps la bourre radin mais
prison jamais un bon jour êtes jaloux
oui on est meilleur que vous admettez le
cet arriviste mesquin roll hall à la
manipulateur capricieux on dirait une
diva vous êtes hypocrite ça c'est le
pire par derrière boom toujours cette
annonce a révélé qu'un producteur vous
appelle vous changer d'opinion
vous êtes menteur ça c'est le plus gros
défaut de ce soit en vous c'est vrai que
vous êtes mégalomane et enfin je dirais
mathieu que vous êtes prétentieux et ça
c'est insupportable vous devez
redescendre alors pour vous j'ai adopté
un nouveau système de notation aa tout
seigneur tout honneur national pour
chacun des défauts j'ai retiré un point
donc ça vous laisse une très belle note
10 - 16 ça fait moins 6,6
et franchement ici on est généreux on
est généreux donc c'est avec beaucoup de
fierté et d'émotion que j'ai arrondi
cette note et je vous donne un sublime 0
[Applaudissements]
il a bien préparé je le vois cette
nuit-là du slovène preco ouais c'est
bien bosser ça là je reconnais que ces
saboteurs